[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRIS CRAIK: Hey, I'm Chris
Craik from the Android
framework team.
YIGIT BOYER: My name is Yigit.
I also work in the
Android framework team,
and today, we are
going to talk about how
to handle large lists with
paging and RecyclerView.
Now, list UI is a very common
thing in Android applications.
Pretty much every single
app has a list of something
they want to display.
So if you're using
architecture components,
let's see how you would
model a list like this.
So you'll have a
view model where
you keep the list of items so
that it survives configuration
change.
You put your data
into the database
so that your application
works offline.
And of course, you have
some server side component
where you pull the data from.
But usually, data is dynamic.
It changes.
So to handle these changes,
you will ask database
to return your LiveData
of list of things
or an observable list
of things so that you
can handle the updates.
For instance, if you
pulled the updated version
of two records
from your database,
and you inserted and
then Room realizes,
oh, there's a query
observing this table,
let me reveal the result,
paste it over to the ViewModel,
and then your UI can
pull from the ViewModel
and update itself with
the correct animations.
This looks cool, but there
is actually a problem here.
There's something we don't like.
To better understand
the issue, let's look
at the interaction between
the database and the UI.
So when I mention that database
is going to rebuild the result,
it is going to rebuild
all of the results.
So if you ask for the user's
order by their last name,
and if you have
10,000 users, it's
going to create 10,000 users,
paste it over to the UI,
and it's very inefficient
because user only
sees 8 to 10 items.
Why would you
create 10,000 items?
So we don't like it.
We want to change this.
So what are we looking for here?
First, we like that convenience.
It's so nice to
tell the database,
give me a LiveData
of list of users.
We want the same convenience.
We want it to handle
multiple layers.
We want to be able to
bring data from the server,
put it in the database,
and put in the UI.
And this should be
very easy to implement.
We want it to be fast.
We don't want it to do
any unnecessary work.
We don't want it to do any big
chunk of work in the UI thread.
It should be efficient.
We want it to be
lifecycle aware.
So if user's not
looking at the screen,
it shouldn't do any work.
Last but not least, we
want it to be flexible.
Everybody has their different
back end APIs, different data
structures.
Our solution should work
with all of these things.
Now, if we go back
to our first example,
how do we implement these
lists if we don't use paging?
If you're using Room in your
Dao, you specify your query.
You tell it to return a
LiveData of list of users.
Now, in your ViewModel,
you hold a reference to it
and serve it to your UI.
In your activity, you will
use this list activity-- list
adapter clause,
but if you're not
following our
releases closely, you
may not have heard about it.
Let's focus on that one.
ListAdapter is a RecyclerView
adapter that displays a list.
So if you have the
RecyclerView on the right, when
you call sumbitList
method on the adapter,
it just displays it.
The nice thing is, if you
pull the same submitList
method with a
different list, it's
going to calculate the
difference between these two
lists on a background
thread and update the UI
with the correct animations.
This is available in
RecyclerView 27.1,
and the same function also
exists in the AsyncListDiffer
class if you cannot
extend the adapter.
Let's go back to our example.
We have our adapter.
We observed the LiveData.
We send the list to the adapter.
So for when we
initialize the adapter,
we need to give it a callback.
So let's do functionalities.
First, it can check if two
items are equal identically,
and the other one checks
whether their contents are equal
or not.
So we can decide whether we need
to remind those views or not.
Once you have that, your
onBindViewHolder method,
you can call the
getItem function,
obtain the item in the list, and
do whatever you want with it.
Super simple.
CHRIS CRAIK: All
right, so we see
what that looks like
with a LiveData of list,
but you also started out with--
this isn't good enough.
So let's look at what this
looks like when you're
using new Paging library.
So first of all, the
most important component
of the Paging library
is the PagedLists,
and this is a list that
implements the listed or face,
but it loads data in
pages asynchronously.
It's backed by a class called a
data source that provides data
as the page list needs it, swaps
it in, and updates the list.
So this serves as a
replacement for the list
in all the examples
that we've done before.
So let's go ahead and
start swapping it out.
We have this ViewModel.
Let's swap out the
list with a PagedList,
and then we go back to our Dao.
Now, what we want to do here
is we want to ask our Dao,
hey, can you give me a
LiveData of a PagedList?
But there's actually
an issue with this.
So if we look over at what the
data looks like on the database
side, you could imagine
paging this in one way,
and you could imagine paging
this in a different way.
There's actually some
interesting decision here.
Are you showing
really large items?
tiny items, or you
want to have a lot of
data paged at once?
Well, the page size really needs
to be configurable to serve
every app's needs.
So instead, Room can produce
this data source class that
backs a PagedList, and
that way, the PagedList
can access it and say,
give me item 6 through 12
and load those data
directly into the PagedList.
Now, because we say that
we want multiple of them,
though-- remember that we want
something that's observable,
so we just wrap
that in a factory.
Every time that we need a new
PagedList out of the database,
we create a new data source.
All right, so instead of
the LiveData of PagedList,
what the user now
provides us here
is a data source factory
keyed off of Integer
because we're using positions.
So we go back to
our ViewModel here
and define how are we
going to load this data.
Well, it's not much code.
We just say get the
data source factory
that we just declared
in our user Dao
and use this live
PagedListBuilder class
from the library to
create a LiveData.
The minimum amount of data
that you need to pass here
is page size.
And here, we're passing 30.
That's it.
Now, you have a
LiveData of PagedList.
So now, all of the repository
side changes are done.
The ViewModel's updated.
Let's go to the activity.
So now, we were using
listAdapter before.
Well, simply you change this
into a PagedListAdapter.
A PagedListAdapter is the exact
same thing as listAdapter.
It just happens to handle
the loading of pages
as content is internally
updating in those page lists.
So if we look at how we'd
actually implement this list
adapter, though, we'd
have to switch over
to the new PagedListAdapter
and use the exact same diff
callback.
We don't have to
change any code there.
The only thing that
changes as part
of implementing this
on the adapter side
is that the user object
becomes nullable,
and we'll get into why
in just a little bit.
So let's go through how you
can do further configuration,
because we don't stop
at just page size.
So the code that we showed
before of creating a live
PagedListBuilder-- you can
simply just pass a minimum
page--
a page size, and that's
the minimum amount of data
that you need to pass.
But you can also create
a configuration object
where you can declare more.
So one thing that
you might want to do
is set an initial load size
hint, and this-- what this does
is it requests that the
initial load is larger
to make that initial load
avoid initial page fetches
immediately after
you've fetched it.
Another thing that you can
change is prefetch distance.
By default, this
is the page size,
but you can
configure this if you
know that your data source
is higher or lower latency.
You can also control
placeholders,
which are an important
part of this library,
so let's start
talking about those.
So Placeholders False is
kind of the default paging
that you might have--
the expectation
that you might have,
where typically you
load the first page.
The RecyclerView has access
to the number of items
that you've loaded,
and you see, well, you
have a big scroll bar.
The user can scroll
through it, and once they
get to the bottom,
there's no more data.
Once the page loads,
the scroll bar jumps,
and the user is able
to scroll forward.
So we also support a completely
different type of paging
here that presents
this differently.
If you asked for
placeholders, and this
is the default in the library,
we will present your lists
like this.
You notice here that the scroll
bar is a little bit smaller,
and that's because
we're presenting
the entire data set to the
RecyclerView immediately.
That scroll bar won't jump
while we're scrolling.
As the user scrolls
down, you see
that there are unloaded
items, and those are presented
as nulls in the adapter.
These items, as the
data eventually loads,
display, and you'll get a
nice animation for that.
So let's talk about
placeholders because they
don't work everywhere, but
we think that they're really
useful in a lot of cases.
So one of the big
positives of them
is that the user can
scroll past what's loaded.
The user doesn't have to
hit a block at the very end
because you don't have
any more data yet.
The scroll bar looks
correct instantly,
and also this is
very important, you
can use fast
scroller very easily
because you have the
entire data set presented
to the RecyclerView so
you can jump anywhere.
And then another nice
feature is that you
don't have to implement a
loading spinner at the bottom
because the users can
see the placeholder.
They can see that there's a
gray icon instead of a user icon
and know that that
item is still loading.
There are some downsides,
though, of placeholders.
First of all, it's
pretty important
that your items
stay the same size.
If you can't guess what the item
height is going to be before
you have content-- for
instance, if you have, say,
a social media post with an
arbitrary amount of text--
the crossfade animation
doesn't look great.
Additionally, your
adapter has to be
able to handle null items, so
that's a little bit more code
that you have to write to
say, if this item doesn't
exist, pass an empty
string to the text view,
that kind of thing.
And then your data source has
to be able to count items.
Now, Room can count
items out of the box,
but if you're using something
that is loading data
from, say, the
network, your back end
may not be able to
provide a precise count.
So we've been talking a lot
about LiveData thus far,
but as Yig introduced at
the beginning, there's--
we also want to support
our RxJava developers.
So instead of
producing a LiveData,
you may want to produce,
say, an observable,
and we provide the
class RxPagedListBuilder
to do exactly that.
So you can change
the return type here,
use an RxPagedListBuilder, and
then just specifically request
an observable or a
flowable out of it.
And you get all
the same behavior.
You can use all the same code
that we were showing before,
with a little bit of change
to switch you Rx observation.
Now, let's go under
the hood, because we've
shown how small of
a code change this
can be to switch
the Paging library,
but how does that
work underneath?
So here, on the left,
you have the repository
that represents the data loading
portion of your application.
And then you, on the right,
you have the ViewModel,
which is how it
communicates to the UI.
So inside the
repository, we want
to build the source
for this LiveData.
We want to produce
something that
will push updates to the UI.
So when you call
LivePageListBuilder.build,
we create not only
a LiveData that
can be used to funnel
information to the UI,
but the producer side as well.
Once someone starts
observing that LiveData,
we will create a new
page list, because that's
the way that we start passing
information down this pipeline.
And to do that, we create
a new data source out
of the factory that we--
that Room is able to produce.
Now, to pass this
page list over,
though-- we don't want
to send an empty list.
If the UI can avoid it, we'd
really like to load data first.
And so we do that on
a background thread,
initialize that data, and
create a PagedList out of it.
And here, you can see
at the very beginning,
the first PagedList that we
produce has data only loaded
at the very front.
We can send that over
to the UI thread.
And then, if you remember,
our submitList call
on PagedListAdapter submits
this to the adapter.
And the adapter can
start immediately
presenting those items.
Now, as the user
scrolls, though, we
might need to load more data.
So the PagedList, internally,
will trigger a data load
from its data source and
append that data directly
to the PagedList.
Now, the crossfade
animation occurs
because we have signaled
the RecyclerView
that these new items
are updated again,
but what happens when a
content update occurs?
So if the database says, oh,
this table has been validated,
something has changed,
we immediately
stopped loading from
the data source.
We invalidate it.
So let's look at
what happens in order
to start pushing those updates,
though, from the other side.
So on the other side of
things, we can see, oh, well,
the database had an
item added to it.
That's why we invalidated
the previous data source.
And at the same time,
the producer side
is listening to the
signal to know I need
to produce a new PagedList.
So we use this signal
to create a new data
source so that we can create
a new PagedList to send over.
And when we load the
initial data for that,
though, we're careful
to initialize that
based upon the
loading position that
was signaled by the adapter.
So the user has
partially scrolled down.
So let's center our load
around where the user is.
We send that over to the UI,
and now we submitList again.
But because these are
two different lists,
and we really don't want to
call NotifyDataSetChange, what
happens is that we compute
an asynchronous diff
on a background thread
just like with listAdapter,
as Yig mentioned earlier.
Once that diff is computed,
we pass that diff result
into the RecyclerView and
swap the new PagedList in.
Immediately, you get
a new item showing up,
a new animation for
that, and we only
have to do the minimal
amount of UI work to bind
and show the new item.
So fundamentally, under the
hood, we do a lot of trickery
to make this work.
But from the outside, we try
and make it look as close as
possible to a LiveData
of a list because this
is a really nice experience.
It lets you keep your
UI really, really simple
and avoid all of the information
about paging on that side
and let you configure
and construct
your flow in one place
from the repository.
The PagedListAdapter is able
to handle both the new page
lists as they flow in and
also the internal updates
of the page list as it loads.
YIGIT BOYER: Let's talk
about data sources.
So we mentioned that PagedList
is a list implementation that
works with a data source, and
we have different types of data
sources.
You can have a
PositionalDataSource,
an ItemKeyedDataSource,
and a PageKeyedDataSource.
Let's start with the
PositionalDataSource.
If you have an application
like the Contacts application
on Android, where you
have the data locally,
but user may want to jump
into arbitrary positions,
PositionalDataSource
is your best option.
This is actually what Room
uses behind the scenes.
So if you have a data
source or UI like that,
you extend this
PositionalDataSource class,
and you specify
the type of items.
But to better understand how
this data source behaves,
let's look at an example.
So we have the UI here.
We'll just zoom out, go
to the bird's eye view,
and we have our data source
on the right back by our list.
The very first time you
come to the RecyclerView,
PagedList will call this
LoadInitial method on the data
source, pass the start
position and page size,
and then load size--
InitialLoadSize,
which is usually
larger than the page size,
because you want to have
more items at the beginning--
and whether placeholders
are enabled or not.
In this example, we just assume
placeholders are enabled.
So our data source--
we return the data.
Tell us about where
that data starts,
and it will give us the total
number of items in the data
source.
Based on that, we'll
start displaying the data,
but we'll also display
the placeholders
so that the size of the pages
is equal to the total number
of items in the data source.
Now, a user can start scrolling.
As soon as users
start scrolling,
pages will realize that it's
going to run out of data,
and it's going to
call this LoadRange
method on the
PositionalDataSource,
paste at the start position of
the first item that's missing
and the page size, and get the
new data appended to the list.
So imagine in this case,
user uses the fast scroller
and jumps into an
arbitrary position where
we didn't have the data yet.
When this happens, it won't
call the data source LoadRange
position.
We take positions slight
level RecyclerView and load
that page so that we can
display it to the user.
This is why PositionalDataSource
is really good if user can
jump into arbitrary positions.
You never block them.
Let's say something has
happened in the database.
Data has been invalidated.
So we'll get a new data source.
So each data source represents
a snapshot of the data.
So we get this new one.
We'll create the
new pages for it,
and we'll load the initial
page from this data source
based on where user is
in the previous one.
We'll bring this one, as
always, on a background thread.
We will calculate the difference
between these two lists
and update the RecyclerView
with the correct animations.
Second one is the
ItemKeyedDataSource.
So imagine you have some data,
like a list, list of names.
If you look at the
page out of this,
you could identify the
items before this page
by using the first item in
the list, and the next page
by using the last
item in the list.
Basically, every item
can identify a page
after or before it.
If your data source
is like that,
you should implement the
ItemKeyedDataSource class.
You provide a key type--
in this case, we are
using names, so String--
and the item type in the list.
Let's look at an example.
So first time you come
to the RecyclerView,
it called the
LoadInitial method.
Passed the initial key, which is
null, because we don't have it.
It requests the load size
and whether placeholders
are enabled or not.
We'll just assume they're
not enabled in this example,
so data source will
only return this data.
It's not going to count
it because there's
no placeholders.
So start displaying it.
As soon as users
start scrolling,
we will extract the key from
the last line that we have
and call the data
source LoadAfter
method to load that other page.
Similarly, as user
keeps scrolling,
just extracts a key, and
then loads another page
the same way.
By this point,
let's say this data
was coming from the
database, similarly
something has changed, so
we lost the data source.
It's been invalidated.
We'll get a new data source.
When we create a new PagedList
for this data source,
we are going to extract the key
from one of the items that's
currently visible in the
RecyclerView closer to the top
and load a page from
this new data source.
And we get that page.
We understand these
are PagedLists.
We will calculate the
diff and update the UI
with the correct animations.
Now, we don't take the
data on top anymore.
So if user tries to scroll
up, we need more data.
Same thing-- you just extract
the key from the first item,
call LoadBefore method on the
data source, Get that page,
prepend it to the PagedList, and
now user can scroll outwards.
So it's always lazy,
always reactive.
Third one is the
pagedKeyedDataSource.
Now, this is a really common
way of paging, especially
on the server side APIs.
So your client sends a request,
and when the response comes in
from the server, it
includes the data.
It also includes pointers for
the next and previous keys.
GitHub API works this way.
Reddit API works this way.
It's very common.
So if you have a data
source like that,
you should implement the
PagedKeyedDataSource, specify
the type of your keys that
you use in the pointers,
and the item type.
Let's look at the example.
First time user comes to the UI.
We call LoadInitial.
We give it a size, and we
ask whether placeholders
are enabled or not.
They're usually disabled because
your server doesn't give you
an accurate count.
We'll just assume
they're disabled--
easier.
And then the data
source returns the data,
but it also gives us
pointers for the previous key
and the next page key.
Now, we start displaying it.
If user scrolls, we
need more contact.
So we're going to call
the LoadAfter method,
use the key that was returned
in the previous request
to get the next page
from the data source.
Now, this next page comes with a
field called AdjustmentPageKey,
so it always tells, OK,
what is the next page
in this direction?
It's literally like a
linked list of pages.
Once you take that,
user can scroll more.
Now, a difference
in this data source
is how we handle invalidation.
Imagine user hit the Refresh
button on the screen.
Data source is invalidated.
We'll get a new data source,
but in the LoadInitial method,
there is no key anymore.
This is because--
I mentioned, this is
like a linked list.
So if the previous list is
invalid, links in the list
doesn't mean anything.
So you always need to load
the very first page again
and display it in the UI.
This is usually not
a problem in practice
because you only do this if
a user does swipe to refresh,
so they are already
on top of the list.
CHRIS CRAIK: All
right, so Yig talked
through what we might see
implementing a data source,
but what happens when we want
to load from multiple sources
at once?
So a database plus
network solution--
these two components
can work really
nicely together when
the database acts
as a cache for the network.
You can page from
your back end that you
have with all the benefits
of the local cache.
You can have a really
nice offline support.
You can resume quickly if the
application has been killed
and restarted, and you can
minimize network traffic
by taking advantage of data
that's already on device.
So let's look at how
this might look compared
to what we were showing before
with a single source of data.
So how does the network
fit into this system?
So one way that we could do
this is we could basically say,
well, the network is my source
of data when I'm connected,
and the database is my
source when I'm not.
So if I'm connected, then I
page data from the network,
and if I'm not, I page
data from the database.
The one problem there is that
you don't have anything storing
data in your database even
when you're loading a network,
but it's pretty easy.
As a side effect of
loading from the network,
you can just store
in the database,
and there, you have
paging from both.
However, this is a couple
of really big problems
that are important to discuss.
So this switching model
has the first problem
that this connected state
is really oversimplifying.
In reality, individual
request to your servers
can succeed and fail,
and a user that's
connected, like, 20%, some
of the packets go through.
That doesn't really fit
really nicely into this model.
The other big problem is that
we're not using local data when
it's present, so let's go about
looking at a different way
to do this.
So what if instead we
just monitor the database
and use that as our local
single source of truth?
What we can do
then is we can say,
well, the only time
I need to load data
is when the database tells
me that it's out of data.
I can use that as a signal to
load more data from the network
stored into the
database, and then
I have my entire solution
built. I just load data
when I need to,
but I can present
only the database, which
makes things a lot simpler.
So we get the benefits of
consistent data presentation.
We have a similarly
simple process.
But importantly, this
gracefully degrades on failures.
If your user is in that
20% connected state,
you can still produce-- you can
still present all of the data
that you have locally and try
and fetch or potentially retry
when the network is around.
So potentially, you
might say, well,
this doesn't keep my data fresh.
And an easy way to work around
that is to just say, whenever
anyone starts observing
the stream of data,
we start a new fetch.
We see if we need to
refresh our content,
and that's especially
important usually
when you have a
frequently updating data.
So in that proposed
model here that we saw,
we need an out of data
signal from the database.
Because the rest of that,
we've basically already built
in the first few slides.
So when we have that
signal, we can trigger loads
from the network directly
into the database,
and the UI doesn't have
to enter into any of that.
So paging built exactly this
signal for exactly this reason,
and we call that the
boundary callback.
So let's go ahead and look
at what that might look like.
So the first most important part
of the boundary callback that
you implement is that you
pass it to different--
that you'll want to provide it
two different sources of data--
the database and the network--
because that's its job.
So the first-- the important
callback that we have here
is onItemAtEndLoaded.
And this signifies the
last item in the database
has been loaded
from the PagedList,
and if there's more from the
network, it's time to load it.
So the first thing that
we do in response to this
is that we, over on
a network thread,
we can request our service--
hey, give me more data.
And in this
particular case, we're
using the item at the end to
feed which data we need more
of because we're
in an item key case
similar to the item key data
source that you saw before.
Now, if that request
is successful,
we simply jump over to
the database thread,
insert that data that we
loaded from the response
into the database, and
we're basically done.
We've connected that
signal that we needed,
and now we've added
network to something
that was purely database.
Now, the one other
trick that you
need to be aware of, though,
is that it's possible,
when the database is
being invalidated locally
for multiple at end signals to
trigger-- so what you can do
is you can just protect this
with a simple Boolean to say,
if I'm already
loading, don't try.
And then we can reset
that at the end.
So using this boundary
callback is pretty simple.
You can just add this back into
your live page list builder
or to your Rx page list
builder, and then that
gives you the database plus
network solution all isolated
in that one callback.
So let's talk about what
the Paging Library is.
So the Paging Library
provides paging from database,
network, and importantly
both, as we just
saw, and it can load the data
directly into RecyclerView.
It extends this live data of
list, this observable list
pattern that we really
like because it keeps
our UI incredibly
simple, and it lets
us contain all of the
complex logic on one side.
It's configurable.
We have configurable load size,
prefetch, and placeholders.
And it integrates directly
with Room, with LiveData,
and with Rx.
The Paging 1.0
was just released,
and so please give it a try.
Take it for a spin.
YIGIT BOYER: Hi, that
was a lot of information.
We know.
So where to go next?
Well, we have extensive
documentation on d.android.com.
If you can just read,
we provide more details
and more samples there.
We have an amazing code lab.
You can just check it
out in the Code Lab area,
or you can try it online.
We also have samples
on GitHub where
we implement different data
sources using [INAUDIBLE] API
or a different look
[INAUDIBLE] database,
and you can compare and contrast
the behavior of different data
sources.
And you can also see how
you could handle things
like errors, retries.
We have all of it there.
But if you've been sitting
here for the last 30 minutes,
and wondering whether
these two guys never
heard about Cursor and its
built-in paging, rest assured,
we did hear about that.
So that's actually what
we wanted to use initially
when we started this
project because we already
have Cursor adapters.
It's Cursor.
It takes care of all the work.
Right?
Wrong, so we realize it is very
unpredictable and inefficient
if your cursor becomes large.
So especially fearing your
application currently,
if you are using Cursor for
lazy loading, be very careful.
Room and Paging together
avoids this problem
because we create
much smaller queries,
not to rely on the paging
behavior of Cursor.
Now, it's a very complex topic,
but Chris wrote an amazing blog
post about this, that
you can go to that link,
and we will post this
URL after the talk.
It's amazing, but
TLDR, Cursor's paging
is not the right
way to the paging.
We did it wrong.
We hopefully fixed it this time.
CHRIS CRAIK: Did it wrong
10 years ago, at least.
YIGIT BOYER: 10 years ago.
It's not me.
So paging is part of
Jetpack, our new initiative
to accelerate
Android development.
We had great many
talks at this I/O.
This was the last
one, so please,
if you are not able to
attend those sessions,
check them on Youtube.
Everything is recorded.
And you can also learn more
about Jetpack on our website
and provide us feedback.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]